have you seen the movie uh of american
gangster with uh
who's in it russell crowe is in it with
denzel right am i getting the right
russell crowe right and then there's the
scene where russell crowe is sitting
there and he's got this person at the
top that he's thinking is the main guy
behind blue magic i think it's called
blue magic and you know he's the one
that's doing it and then all of a sudden
he realizes no no the guy out there all
the way at the top is
frank lucas right and frank lucas
three-quarters of a billion dollars
during that time of year and anyways
later on he comes in and he throws
everybody else under the bus or whatever
happened with the case at the end of the
movie
but so you said fitzgerald muller you
say all these names right and the same
thing they don't do trump comey right
all these names you're saying
who is the boss of them that's like who
are they supporting who's the guy at the
top when you play the same game
i'm not even sure i know um
i i
to this day i'm still trying to sort it
out and figure it out i do believe that
there was some collusion
with the democratic house speaker and
chairman of the party michael madigan
who's now facing federal intense federal
housing investigation i do believe there
may there was a collusion when they
impeached me because they wouldn't allow
me to play tapes you see here's the
thing you guys
patrick and adam
they taped me for six weeks they played
snippets selected snippets of
conversation out of context to make me
look
bad this is [ __ ] cold and i'm not
giving it up for nothing that was the
day after the election that was the day
after i was approached by this labor
boss who said barack called me the night
before wants to talk to you about a
senate seat what do you want so i
mentioned that to my aides we discussed
what can we get for this
and there was no they don't play the
rest of the tape where
um you know the conversation is put in
the proper context do you have that do
you have the recording i have all those
tapes i've had them for years but we're
not allowed to play them publicly
because immediately after they played
those snippets and arrested me they went
right into court and got a seal order to
keep those tapes under seal and it's
against the law if you release them and
then we tried repeatedly in court to
play those tapes at the trials i was
promised by the judge in the second
trial that if i agreed to testify i
could play the tapes to corroborate my
testimony so i agreed to get up there
and testify because i knew that if i
testified i'm not the tapes the
prosecutor's gonna do exactly what he
did and then just lie to the jury and
say go back to the jury room and see how
many times you hear tapes corroborating
what he says well i get up there they
won't play the tapes to this day they
won't play the tapes and the tapes show
a very different story from what they
tried to have people believe they are
lion scumbags they're corrupt
[ __ ] you can say that here
right yeah you can't believe it but love
you guys you know i was watching it i
was watching uh uh the part where you're
like i'm gonna testify i will testify
i'm gonna show you wait till you hear it
i want everybody to be up there i'm the
opposite of a you know nixon nixon said
no i want i want everything to be out
there and then when it comes down to it
you didn't testify and you said your
lawyer wanted you to testify but the
father encouraged you to not testify
because you don't have to and you said
something if there's one thing that i'm
guilty of it's sometimes i you know talk
too much or something like that he said
right
from your end i mean i've heard the
answer on the documentary unless if
there's a different answer
why didn't you eventually testify if
that's if you know you're innocent why
don't you testify right well i did at
the second trial what you're talking
about in that hulu documentary is the
first trial yeah and at that point their
case was so ridiculously
not there was no crimes that the
decision by the lawyers was
don't even bother putting a defense on
they proved nothing
and so therefore if you don't put a
defense on you can't testify so that's
what happened and
all those charges none of them were the
convict the corruption charges none of
them were convictions okay they were all
uh hung jury so they declared a mistrial
i didn't realize they can try you
forever they try a second time but we
didn't if i was successful the second
time they tried tried me a third time
but so they tried me the second time and
there i testified on the promised by the
judge that if i agreed to testify i
could play the tapes to corroborate my
testimony and the judge lied and i got
up there and i wasn't allowed to play
those tapes and the prosecutor lied
directly to the jury he's a liar his
name is reed shah and i challenge him to
challenge me he went up for the jury and
lied and said you're gonna testify about
the senate seat go back into the jury
room and hear how many times you hear
tapes
if there were 102 conversations on that
on the one particular subject that he
was accusing me of lying about and he
knew those tapes existed and they
wouldn't play them so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye
[Music]